[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be diving into some
common misconceptions about the
Wizarding World uncovering aspects of
The Wizarding universe that even die
hard fans sometimes get wrong if you
fancy yourself a Harry Potter expert
then sit back relax and see if any of
these Harry Potter misconceptions apply
to you let's get into it hogw letters
arrive on 11th birthdays you might
believe that receiving your hogwart's
acceptance letter is magically
synchronized to your 11th birthday for a
truly Unforgettable celebration however
facts revealed that Hogwart sends
letters to all students at the same time
every year regardless of their birth
date this momentous occasion typically
occurs a couple of weeks before the
start of the new term giving all
students from wondrous Wizards to
marvelous muggle borns ample time to
prepare for their magical education
ravenclaw's symbol is a raven it's easy
to assume that Rowena ravenclaw's house
with its raven-like name would adopt the
Raven as its symbol however the emblem
representing this esteemed house is
actually the noble Eagle a bird renowned
for its Keen intelligence and piercing
Vision the eagle perfectly embodies The
house's core values of wit wisdom and
the pursuit of knowledge Ravenclaw
colors aren't silver and blue the
Beloved Harry Potter movies brought JK
rling magical Universe to life but
certain artistic Liberties led to a few
minor
inconsistencies one such deviation is
the portrayal of Ravenclaw house colors
instead of the evocative combination of
bronze and blue described in the books
the films present a silver and blue
Motif though visually captivating it
doesn't capture the true essence of
ravenclaw's values all slytherins are
evil Slytherin house is often miss
misunderstood and to an extent vilified
due to the actions of Infamous dark
Wizards hailing from its ranks however
we must remember the sage words of Alber
stumblor that it is our choices that
shape us far more than our abilities or
affiliations as illustrated by Heroes
like sever Snape and regulus black zuin
is home to more complexities and moral
discrepancies than a blanket statement
of evil can Encompass a phoenix can only
be owned by Dumbledore vks the Regal and
loyal Phoenix is undoubtedly linked with
the great Alba Dumbledore yet the
concept of Phoenix's being exclusive to
The Dumbledore lineage is false in The
Wider Wizarding World these fiery and
mysterious creatures can form strong
connections with all sorts of
individuals who appreciate and honor
their Majestic and magical traits
phoenixes are rare but not singularly
aligned for instance the magical
Menagerie in diagonale is known to
occasionally Stomp these magnificent
fiery Birds invisibility cloaks are
unique to Harry Harry's invisibility
cloak one of the three fa Deathly
Hallows is undoubtedly special however
it should be noted that other
invisibility cloaks do exist in the
Wizarding World they just don't possess
the same rare Properties or history as
Harry's durmstrang and bobor are single
gender schools while the movies
illustrate durmstrang and Bator as
single gender schools the novels
clarified that each School comprises a
diverse array of magical talents
regardless of gender this misconception
SS from visual limitations within the
film
adaptations voices don't change with
poly juu potion the Harry Potter films
inaccurately depict that when using poly
juice potion The Voice remains unchanged
save for the exceptional portrayal of
Bary crunch Jr in contrast JK rolling
Source material makes it clear that when
in individual consumes poly juice potion
they adopt the target's appearance as
well as their voice making for a more
comprehensive and immersive
transformation Hogwarts is located in
England Hogwarts Castle the mighty
educational Fortress we all dream of
attending is often associated with
England this however is not the case in
reality this esteemed Academy of
Witchcraft and Wizardry resides in the
rugged breathtaking region of the
Scottish Highlands A fitting location
for the secrecy and Grandeur that the
Castle's Legacy demands only good
wizards can cast a petronus though evil
wizards casting a petronis is
exceedingly rare it's not impossible the
ability to cast a Patronus though
strongly aligned with those who are
morally good does not entirely exclude
those with a more evil temperament the
best example of this is Dolores Umbridge
who is able to conjure a cat paternus
demonstrating that light magic in some
instances can be harnessed by people
with dark Hearts this highlights the
strength of Will and determination as
instrumental factors in harnessing power
Hogwarts is the only School of magic
while Hogwart School of Witchcraft and
wiery holds a special place in our
magical Hearts it isn't the only magical
School in existence many others of magic
can be found across the globe each with
its unique history practices and
cultures prominent examples include
derring raru baton Casto Bru kovet and
more time Turners can change the past
time traveling is a tantalizing plot
device sprinkled throughout fiction but
in the wising World of Harry Potter time
Turners don't behave as we might expect
instead these magical artifacts operate
under novikov's self-consistency
principle which posits that changes made
in the past will already have been taken
into account historically the evidence
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of aaban
finale where Harry saves his younger
self from Dementors using a Patronus
despite not knowing that he had already
done so Avada kadavra can't be blocked
the killing curse of AR kadavra is
arguably the most infamous dark spell in
The Wizarding Community famously known
for being unblockable however we mustn't
forget the extraordinary Power of Love
which safeguarded from this very curse
when the magic of love the strongest and
most ancient bond that transcends mere
incantations teamed up with the
legendary Lily Potter sacrifice not even
the deadliest curse could Triumph no one
can apparate or disapparate in Hogwarts
Apparition and disapparition within
Hogwarts is typically impossible due to
powerful protective enchantments
enveloping the castle nonetheless
exceptions do exist Alba Dumbledore in
his extraordinary magical expertise
managed to lift these enchantments
temporarily allowing himself and Harry
to apparate during their quest for the
HRS in a Seaside Cave Muggles and
wizards are entirely separate though the
international statute of Wizarding
secrecy actively Endeavors to maintain a
strict divide between the Wizarding and
Muckle worlds it would be an
exaggeration to claim total isolation
after all muggleborn witches and wizards
carry the magical bloodline forward
and muggle authorities such as the
British prime minister are aware of
Magic's existence hence while preserving
their unique identities these two Realms
occasionally coexist and intersect most
Wizards can fly without a broom the
notion that most Wizards can perform
unsupported flight is misleading in
reality only a handful most notably
Voldemort and S Snape demonstrate this
exceptional ability for most other
witches and wizards the trusty broomer
Remains the preferred mode to take to
the skies prophecies don't always come
true while the prophecy concerning the
boy who lived played a pivotal role in
shaping the events of the Harry Potter
series it's crucial to recognize that
prophecies don't necessarily come true
as Albert Dumbledore sagely emphasized
prophecies tend to be more complex than
surface level interpretations would
dictate which is why it's unwise to
consider them Absolute Ironclad
determinants of Destiny Ching yourself
as Secret Keeper the fidelus charm is a
powerful spell that conceals a secret
within a designated secret Keeper's Soul
ensuring that only this individual can
disclose it many fans have asserted that
embeding the secret within the same
person it protects is impossible however
Canon would suggest otherwise for
example we know that bill Weasley is the
secret keeper for Shell Cottage and
Arthur Weasley is the secret keeper for
the burrow
assuming that these are their places of
residence this proves that a person who
lives in the house being protected can
also be eligible to be its Secret Keeper
the only ambiguity here is that the
fidelus charm placed on shell Cottage in
the borrow was designed to protect the
home itself in the case of say the vter
family this may not have worked as it
was the family that needed to be the
subject of the charm and not necessarily
the home Voldemort Soul was split seven
times not eight v initially created six
hres by splitting his soul into various
objects however he inadvertently turned
Harry into Haw rugs and also retained a
fragment of his soul in his own body
this technically means that Voldemort's
Soul was split into eight parts not
seven as believed by some the number of
times his soul was split and the total
pieces of his soul are figures that are
often conflated James Potter was a
chaser not a Seeker contrary to common
fan perception and even some indications
in both the movies and the books JK
rling has revealed that James Potter was
actually a chaser and not a Seeker on
the Hogwarts Quidditch team this may
surprise fans But ultimately the author
has final Authority on her characters
and that's it for this video were any of
these news to you be honest let me know
down in the comment section below until
next time remember differences of habit
and language are nothing at all if our
aims identical and our hearts are
open